[Música]
eu tenho uma confissão para fazer para
vocês eu era viciado viciado e respostas
eu corria atrás de resposta eu tinha que
ter a resposta eu competir com resposta
eu era um atleta de resposta e eu não
sei quando não conseguia dar a resposta
que era maioria das vezes eu sentia
muito mal
e o pior é que sente uma culpa e hoje
pensando acho que eu queria corresponder
a imagem que muitos vocês têm que
japonesa inteligente
eu tenho 45 anos de design de respostas
design respostas em forma de caricatura
ilustração capa de revistas pinturas de
moto customização de motos dentro de
ônibus e de avião privada ambiente de
arquitetura tudo para responder uma
coisa chamada briefing
hoje o vídeo que essa foi minha vida a
dois anos atrás eu vivia uma angústia
uma ansiedade eu me ocupava antes do
momento que quer dizer preocupado com
tudo tinha que saber a tendência de
cinco anos primavera verão e toda essa
história de eu tô me ver e vamos embora
com a co
e aí deu um basta
não basta porque eu estava beirando ou
já estava na depressão e deu um basta
para fazer um doutorado de mim mesmo
esse dourado tem a ver com o
autoconhecimento
fui para o chile uma escola onde nasceu
o coaching ontológico lógico
o coaching ontológico ele visa
acompanhar e entender o indivíduo no seu
processo de aprendizado e oportunizar
novas ações diante de uma expansão da
percepção do aluno de si próprio e foi
pra lá teve três pontos no início do
curso que me chamou atenção primeiro a
emoção é tudo que a moção que foi bonita
do ambiente de trabalho ela chave pra
resolver as coisas ea emoção ela gera
ação ea razão a conclusão segundo ponto
foi observador que eu sou e que todo
mundo é agora tem um macete ele separado
do que eu vejo e do que eu interpreto e
essa interpretação é como eu nasci como
vi como aprendi ver o mundo
isso nos faz todos aqui
observadores e únicos o terceiro ponto
eu aprendi os nossos inimigos de
aprendizagem que muito interessante e eu
com 61 anos nunca entrei numa escola
para falar meu inimigo de aprendizado e
aí eu vejo que o ensino pode estar
ligada de uma ótica da escola para o
aluno e aprendizado do aluno na escola
e aí eu aprendi alguns que eu vou são
vários
o primeiro é ter dificuldade dizer que
eu não sei
o outro é eu sou assim nascia assim vou
continuar assim não posso aprender nada
o outro é sua incapaz de desaprender a
aprender algo novo não sei que não sei
esse também é o outro e também tem um
outro que é ou não do reconhecimento a
quem ensina ou outra eu quero aprender
só no ambiente de muita gravidade e
intensidade longe da leveza e segue
protocolado também eu gosto de aprender
só no lugar de a disney era de gozação
este é meu inimigo
e o outro é estudo estudo estudo e não
pratico coisa que parece de auto escola
não faz teoria não pega o volante e tem
um outro também com esse universo de
informações confunde informação com
sabedoria
agora eu tenho aqui antes de falar o meu
que pra quem gosta de estrutura para
lixar definir a vida esse aqui é para
refletir
eu não comércio fazer se não tá tudo
claro tudo tem que estar claro para
começar
esse é parente do ótimo é inimigo do bom
e o meu sou a dita respostas
descobri o meu inimigo de aprendizado
adquirido há respostas e aí eu comecei a
pensar pô inimigo de aprendizado tem a
ver com o meu mundo diz cassez que seria
no mundo de abundância quem seria o meu
amigo de aprendizado e aí me deu um
estalo falei pô eu tenho um amigo de
aprendizagem e não amigo é uma amiga se
chama pergunta e eu comecei a ficar tão
feliz com a pergunta e com essa
intimidade eu vi que ela não é uma
pergunta comum
ela tem um sobrenome uma pergunta
silenciosa é uma pergunta é uma amiga
que me leva a uma serenidade e não
aquela ansiedade e essa serenidade me
leva a valorizar o meu presente na minha
presença como um presente
é quando essa amiga me leva dentro de
mim onde o connectu o meu silêncio a
minha atitude ea maioria das vezes a
minha aceitação
eu vejo que essa amiga é muito
importante no mundo de muita informação
de muita coisa de fora muita biografia e
quando você não sente o que você tá
vendo
então tá aí eu tenho as emoções que
mostrou em tudo eu tenho um observador
que eu sou eu vejo interpreta e agora
tem a minha amiga silenciosa e aí surgiu
um momento maravilhoso de usar isso
expandir o significado das palavras
aqui vocês estão vendo tem uma nuvem de
emoções e sentimentos
eu faço parte de uma equipe de 200
pessoas de design e lá não é uma área de
design é uma escola que a gente
experimenta muita coisa e vivencia
depois senti teorias um pouco ver isso e
aquilo né pra poder replicar dentro da
estrutura e esse é o ritual de quando
você entra numa reunião essas palavras
são destaque que apareceram no check-in
emocional quando você chega e fala como
é que você está sentindo e tem uma
conversa aí tem um assunto da reunião e
depois como é que você vai sair da
reunião com o check out e sair uma
palavra
isso é muito importante porque o início
da reunião você sabe que tom que tenta
as pessoas e quando sai essa emoção é
emoção do lugar que elas vão executar o
que foi tratado na reunião
e nós estamos desenvolvendo isso e aí
como é que eu aplico aquele aquela
equipe de três né da emoção emoção daqui
observador e à minha amiga silenciosa
eu gosto desse nome que parece uma milha
silenciosa e perfumada uma coisa que me
acompanha há muito aqui ok
e aí a primeira pergunta é sobre o amor
a pergunta é como o amor pode ser a alma
do meu aprendizado
a segunda é o autoconhecimento em nota
que essas palavras sempre foi o foram
usadas
o convite é de nós expandir o uso dessa
palavra para não ficar uma coisa mais
uma palavra autoconhecimento como outro
conhecimento pode gerar a reforma
interior da minha transformação
considerando que a transformação você
transcende uma formação
criatividade é a palavra que se fala
muito né
como habitar minha criatividade com
excesso de recursos como considerar a
minha criatividade é resultante do meu
processo de libertação quando criança
nós éramos criativos e satisfação como
estar satisfeito com a satisfação dos
outros aprendizado como aprendizado sem
viver como é o meu aprendizado sem viver
o desconforto felicidade com a minha
felicidade pode ser a subtração do óbvio
da minha vida para emergir o essencial
curiosidade como considerar a minha
curiosidade como o potencial de eu ir
mais longe
aquilo que fala dentro de nós como meu
inimigo de conhecimento pode não ser a
ignorância mas sim a ilusão de
conhecimento com a oportunidade dada na
minha inquietude que eu tenho de ser o
momento para eu conectar com o meu
autoconhecimento reflexão até mais de
uma que tem essa história da da pergunta
silenciosa com uma reflexão pode ser a
inovação e o mundo de muita resposta
rápida e de certeza absoluta que a mãe
não vale mais com a minha reflexão
diante da distinção de um mundo
produtivo e um do construtivo como estar
em uma escola onde as notas são pelas
reflexões e não pelas respostas alegria
como posso explorar minha alegria
através da alegria do outro
inspiração como a minha inspiração pode
ser resultante da dessa libertação
interna considerando que inspiração é
você respirar por dentro de si
libertar por dentro inspiração como
posso conseguir inspiração aqui neste
encontro para impactar a inovação nas
pequenas coisas de gestos que eu nem
percebo como a esperança com a palavra
esperança como pode ser o meu pedaço de
timing que sabe que vai dar certo e tá
falando aqui para os gamers como o meu
preguem pode ser a esperança do meu game
over gratidão na palavra muito falada né
mais do que design mais de startup e
inovador
botinhas que não chegou aqui acho que
também está o que faz quando a gratidão
retorna embrulhada em um presente seu
presidente isso aqui eu quero dizer o
seguinte foi um presente da minha esposa
que estava do lado povo é ter uma frase
claro vou falar que essa frase de sofia
me ofertou essa gratidão como minha
gratidão pode ser além de que amplia o
valor de impacto na inovação do meu
proposta é isso que nós estamos aqui e
aí tudo isso né que estamos vendo o
quanto que nós estamos expandindo
aprendizado felicidade curiosidade
passamos por todos esses momentos
e aí eu vejo que nós construímos juntos
e vendo essa mancha que cada um se
conectou com uma coisa ou não sei eu
quero deixar aqui uma última pergunta
silenciosa
eu diria não a última mas qual seria
essa pergunta silenciosa que ofertar ia
para esse momento eu pensei depois de
várias versões e saiu uma frase que eu
quero ofertar para vocês porque estou
aqui
arigatô pela oportunidade
[Aplausos]